Film Courage: If Spike Lee didn’t make SHE’S
GOTTA HAVE IT, would you be a filmmaker today?
Adisa, Writer/Director: Wow?
For you to ask that question it’s so poignant
because it’s likely that I wouldn’t.
And it’s very likely that I wouldn’t.
I knew that I wanted to help people.
I knew I wanted a career that was going to
service my community possibly around black
men and what that looked like (rites of passage
programs or whatever).
But the film thing didn’t become a reality
for me until I saw Spike Lee’s early work.
I think it has a lot to do with modeling.
We don’t have a lot of…whether it’s
women or men (black men that is), there is
something to be said about representation
and modeling.
And at the time Spike Lee came around there
wasn’t a lot of black filmmakers.
I mean…that you knew about.
There was Gordon Parks, he had done some work
(SHAFT).
And there was Michael Schultz, he had done
COOLEY HIGH.
I loved the films but I didn’t know particularly
that they were a black man.
There was something about Spike Lee and his
signature work when he was doing SHE’S GOTTA
HAVE IT, DO THE RIGHT THING and it was just
so pronounced and so much of a signature around
black culture and I was like “This is what
I want to do.”
To answer your question which is a really
good question, I don’t know if I would have
been a filmmaker?
Maybe I think I owe my career to Spike Lee.
I don’t know if I would have been led down
that path, I don’t.
Yes…that’s really powerful.
He has had a profound effect on me in terms
of that.
Film Courage: So you saw the film and then
you decided to attend college at NYU Tisch?
Adisa: Yes.
Well I was going back east, for I was going
to University of Massachusetts and then I
had heard about him making a movie.
And then I saw the movie in New York on my
way to UMass Amherst I was driving across
country with a friend.
I was just amazed.
And so going into UMass Amherst which was
my junior year I said I’m setting an intention,
I’m going to be a filmmaker.
So I was going to do whatever I had to do
to be a filmmaker.
So I started taking film classes, I started
studying film, I starting make films on film
like 16 millimeter Bolex (crank cameras) and
then I decided I was going to apply to NYU.
I made a student film that got a lot of awards
at UMass where I was and I applied to NYU
because Spike Lee went to NYU.
So that was sort of my pulse and my geiger,
he was sort of my North Star if you will.
And I was reading all of the books that he
was reading at that time and I applied to
NYU and got in.
Film Courage: Did you ever get to meet him?
Adisa: I did, I met him first year.
I met him the first year because he came to…there
was a woman named Lisa Jones who had written
his books right.
She was his collaborator on a lot of his film
books and she was at NYU.
She was a few years ahead of me.
And I heard when I got there “Spike likes
to meet with the black students,’ right?
He likes to meet with them first year.
So he invited us all to 40 Acres and a Mule
Filmworks (his production company).
And I was like…just you know…starstuck
because he was my idol.
He is my idol, he’s my hero.
And I just shook his hand and yes…
Film Courage: What did he say?
Adisa: He didn’t say much.
Spike was a presence more than anything else
because he was really soft spoken back then
and he let his work speak that was his thing.
So for a lot of time I was like “Wow, how
is this guy doing this?”
Because in business you have to be aggressive,
you’ve got to be strong.
But Spike is very disciplined, he’s very
focused.
You know you read his books, he would get
up at 6:00 a.m. in the morning, he’d have
a certain quota he’d have to write on a
screenplay.
For the first 6 or 7 years he would do a movie
every year it would come out and that was
his process.
He would wake up at 6:00 a.m. in the morning,
write and then he’d go about doing his thing.
But he was a very disciplined individual.
But yes I was floored, I was floored.
He was my hero.